this is possibly the biggest thing i'm
ever going to announce what is it so we
were talking the other day about who is
the greatest whack packer of all time
blah blah blah blah blah you robin of
course said beetlejuice i said eric the
actor but it was it was moot i mean
it's hard to even pick
who would be better between those two
and there's no doubt that beetlejuice is
certainly the greatest living whack
packer and most definitely one of the
most important people who have ever
graced this show
[Music]
today right now
sitting in a hotel room we have
beetlejuice
yes there is beet god bless you it is so
good to see you beetlejuice the fans
have missed you for five years oh yeah
definitely let me let me reconstruct if
i can the last five years so you move
back in with your mom right right right
your mom who is 70 years old at this
point she decided you needed to have a
low profile in a way she's a genius
because by you being away your legend
has built up even more yeah that's true
beat how old are you at this point do
you i know you don't like it
i'm about 80 years old man wow
your mother that's interesting
yeah 80 years old
you look much younger and you look you
look fantastic yeah
i do
beat how did it come about that we got
you here today i know bobby your manager
is there with you and where are you guys
now in a hotel yeah we know tell just
sitting here just
just thinking you know when you were uh
you were away for the show for five
years who did you miss the most from the
show was it baba bowie was it robin was
it me was was there anyone in particular
well who was it sal
well the only person i miss is you
thank you oh yeah
i see you winking beetle
peter you playing me or what i mean you
really missed me or no i look like i'm
playing with you my friend i still
thinking about you because you're my
friend you don't think about me at all
no he doesn't think about you robin you
know i always think about you cause you
know you always got to get off some ass
every single week
absolutely everyone thinks about robin
uh b will you ever get married will you
ever have children or will you be remain
a bachelor for the rest of your life
what's the thought these days
probably probably next year or something
okay good so there is a special lady
probably are you banging famous women at
all that we might be i don't want to
preach
are there any names you can share with
us uh of top college
i tell you what
you don't wanna [ __ ] around with an old
lady down
i think one of the most beautiful women
in hollywood oh my old lady now she can
[ __ ] now
okay okay all right i understand
oh yeah she can find my old lady what
old lady you're going to tell us who
he's talking about you're [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] an old lady 75 years old
that needed to [ __ ] man
that [ __ ] wrong but she dude won't know
b
who are you you're [ __ ] a 75 year old
woman yeah hell yeah she loved that [ __ ]
really and you say she can [ __ ] and she
she gets really excited huh
oh yeah
yeah wow now i have an exciting
announcement
for beetlejuice
um a lot of people are saying how is
beetle making a living well i'll tell
you there's some exciting beetlejuice
news b you want me to say it or you want
to say it about the bitcoin
bitcoin is good
beet is now involved with this new
cryptocurrency you can buy bitcoin at
getbeatcoin.com he's entered this in a
very very big way now it says here the
current price is a little less than 30
cents it opened up at six cents so it
sounds like you've already made millions
uh oh yeah
you have yes be i am excited that i got
to see you yes my head was spinning with
all kinds of conspiracy theories whether
you were healthy
don't drink too much that's good advice
for everybody you're completely sober
you haven't had a drink how many years
have you not had a drink
i ain't have a drink maybe since up
long time ago a long time ago do you do
you miss it at all do you ever sit there
and say oh i just want a beer i just
want to you know do you ever say it
it doesn't matter
right excuse me
this world has changed so much
but uh if if if you're telling me
you got to change your life man
yep you got to go with the flow and you
don't change your life why are you going
to eat [ __ ] if you don't change your
life and have a beard and change your
life that's a good point are you saying
that in order to get the best [ __ ] you
have to have a lot of money is that kind
of the rule of thumb
you got to grow a beer if you want to
eat [ __ ] you got to grow a beer you got
to grow a beer man
b you don't have a beard and you eat
[ __ ] oh yeah i came a man
i had a bed before bobby will tell you
i'm a real man with a beard
he just shaved it i love you beat i do
and i love you bobby and uh
guys too and uh promise me one thing
before you go don't [ __ ] my wife again
just hands off
[Laughter]
leave her god you can't be done though
you caught me i know please for god's
sakes i love you i love you all right
there he goes beetlejuice everyone bobby
and their new adventure